I'm kind of hearing about Benghazi the
emails emails her email Taylor Clinton's
Damn emails I think we're kind of a
little bit over that and we need to hear
about more substantive issues like the
economy and climate change you hear
sometimes inauthentic I don't personally
believe that I'm really tired of the
well there's a lot of hatred they
dislike her because she went she knows
how to build coalitions to try to solve
issues to try to solve problems people
talk bad about her because she wants to
fight the NRA there's nobody that needs
an Uzi point Lincoln simple hearing
about her as the former president's wife
instead of some of the work that she
actually has done is signatory I think
what I'm tired of getting Valerie
Clinton is just all the focus on foreign
policy like that's the only thing that's
really going on with her I'd like to
hear more about more issues here at home
so things regarding especially children
and families and what we can do to help
working families most of my friends are
concerned about what Hillary Clinton's
going to do to keep this country safe
and create good jobs and good wages and
how she's going to work with those
Republicans on the other side of the
line so